heute um 14 uhr trafen sich kult komiker
otto waalkes und die frau seines
langjährigen managers hans otto mertens
vor dem hamburger landgericht es geht um
den manager vertrag zwischen mertens und
michaels weiters wollte 2016
im zuge der planung einer
deutschlandtour die vergütung von
mertens von 15 auf fünf prozent
herunterstufen die ehefrau von mertens
klagte gegen waalkes und fordert jetzt
52.000 euro
die summe soll der künstler als manager
anteil an der herbsttournee 2016 zahlen
für auftritte und tourneen der
folgejahre fordert mertens noch einmal
170.000 euro ungefähr wieder über das
wirklich was aufnahme heute ja auch
interessant so eine verhandlung live
mitzuerleben als beklagter bin ich gar
nicht gut und ich hoffe natürlich dass
gerechtigkeit sieht das geht aber nur um
geld das da habe ich auch gehört sehr
lange beziehungen für besteht wird daran
nicht zerbrechen wird das erste sein der
kläger war nicht da
zudem kann das gar nicht verstehen aber
mal sehen wie sich das weiter weg ist
lang
sie können sich das gar nicht vorstellen
ich glaube nicht dass er diese klage
genauso oft machen
juni vorstellt kommt dass er von seiner
frau gesagt keine ahnung von sind sehr
netter mann ist und zwischen 50 jahre
quasi wie verheiratet zusammen ist alles
für mich das überraschen aber mal sehen
was daraus nicht war oder doch nur
interessant interessant berechtigt er
weiß immer gucken interessiert das ist
neu für mich weil ich jetzt diese sind
ja meine geschichte aber finde es sehr
interessant ich hoffe das geht zu weit
das weiß man hier zu teilen heißt die
vereinbarung hat so verstanden und war
dann ist gesundheitlich angeschlagene
moment deswegen ist es mehr fürsorge für
so deutlich
[Musik]
aber erst mal vorstellen 50 jahre lang
lang zeit
ich habe zwar nie damit man halt so sein
das ist doch wird gerechtigkeit siegen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht abonnieren